let's start with somebody that you've
covered that I think you've covered a
lot and I'm really embarrassed to not
know much about them I think it's like
old school coffee sale you've been
through stages okay I've been through
stages and phases uh so a character
named Dan Lok yeah uh
who is he you've uh you've exposed him
for cult like
uh human and his cult-like practices who
is he what has he done so Dan Lok is
sort of he's gone through a number of
iterations but he was kind of this like
sales trainer guy who really made a hard
push into what he called high ticket
sales and he was telling people that
they could kind of escape the nine to
five Rat Race if they just learn High
ticket sales and they can have the life
of their dreams basically it's like I'll
teach you to sell but I'll teach you to
ask like not only will I teach you to
sell sell you that pin but I'll teach
you to sell it for fifty thousand
dollars instead of a dollar right
um
so I talked to a lot of the people who
had taken this course because it was
pretty expensive I think it was like
twenty five hundred dollars or a
thousand dollars and mind you the people
who are taking it are like teachers and
like people who don't have a lot of
money and then you take the course and
immediately you find out okay well
there's an upsell at the end of the
course you're not ready you need to go
from like high ticket closer which is
one of the products to Inner Circle or
like the level up right and all of these
courses are structured like this so they
spend a tremendous amount on Google ads
to get people in the door promising the
dream and then once you're in you're
actually not done being like the product
you're actually in this system that
tries to upsell you again and again and
again and again and eventually you're
paying monthly and you're getting more
and more you're constantly paying for
access to Dan locks wisdom and like
ideas and fundamentally
this sales system wasn't working for
people I mean I talked to like for
example a teacher who put in like twenty
five thousand dollars
was in debt at one point and has nothing
to show for it I know and it was sort of
these tactics of pressuring pressuring
pressuring and then anytime anyone would
complain he would try to silence them so
I heard from like
um funny enough this lady was a teacher
as well she put together a Facebook
group basically saying I think this
guy's a scam his course didn't work it's
not working for a lot of people
because fundamentally the promise of
turning someone from a non-salesman into
a person who's making six figures
selling is not an easy thing to do it's
not just a matter of just like take my
course but anyways it wasn't working she
created a Facebook group about it and he
likes suser or and was like legally
pressuring her to stop doing that
um and I realized like somebody has to
speak out about this and everyone who is
is getting silenced so I was like I'm
going to use my platform to raise
awareness to this and people came out of
the woodwork I mean saying that this guy
defrauded me or he scammed me and I want
to just really quickly take a second
take a beat to explain why get rich
quick schemes are different
then let's say selling a water bottle
and saying it's the greatest water
bottle ever right because sometimes
people wonder they go like well doesn't
like
Nissan say their car is going to make
you happy and then it doesn't make you
happy like why is that different from
the kind of advertising of
a get rich quick course I mean both of
them are sort of promising things that
aren't true but you get something you
take some kind of a training you know
isn't it the same thing
no here's why
there's this concept in economics called
elastic demand and inelastic demand
what it essentially means is that if I
raise the value of this water bottle
there's a point at which you're just
going to be like no it doesn't make any
sense right
but there are areas in our lives where
we have desperation around them
that can get deeply predatory very
quickly because they have no
there's no elasticity around their
demand for example your health if you
get cancer and I have the pill
that will solve it or at least let's say
I don't I have a sugar pill here but if
I can convince you that this pill will
solve your cancer or treat your cancer
you will pay any amount of money you
have on this Earth
to get this pill that it but obviously
that gets really predatory really quick
because
selling something that isn't real is
almost as compelling as selling
something that is real right so this
happens in the get rich quick space too
there's any amount of money you would
pay to make a lot more money right
so these products have inelastic demand
that's why you see what is essentially a
few webinars getting sold for twenty
five hundred dollars
courses that literally have identical
videos on YouTube like very similar
curriculums that are selling for such
extravagant amounts of money and
I think there can be comparisons made to
college because obviously there's
similar like questions about benefits
but in this case there's not even
statistics available that even shows the
average person gets something out of it
that's true of like if you go to college
your average income will improve right
that's the justification there there's
none of that there's no case studies
there's nothing backing their
extravagant claims of you're going to
make all this money you're going to make
all this wealth instead they're just as
we said before they're selling you a
dream so that's why I find all those
like types of get rich quick schemes so
problematic and uh that's why I've
railed against them for a significant
amount of time what have you learned
from um attacking exposing some of the
things that Den lock is is doing what
what have you learned about human nature
and and frosters and gurus and so on
that's a great question so
I think one of them is that
there's this systemic problem that
the the phrase there's a sucker born
every minute it's very true there is no
end to the people who will fall for
something like this and the problem is
is because there's just no end to need
and want and like and just lack I mean
it's easy to on the one hand criticize
people's greed but a lot of times you
have to put yourself in their shoes if
you're at a dead-end job
you have nothing going for you you don't
have the money to go to college you want
to get in debt fair play
where do you go right as you said
there's somebody who's there saying they
believe in you they believe you can make
six figures
you know you're you're gonna believe in
that and so
I really felt like
it made a lot more sense to tackle it
from the other side from the side of
people that can stop that can basically
be exposed and basically be
um have sort of like a negative put on
their work I mean they're largely going
under the radar so I kind of felt like
you know do you want to educate the do
you want to like blame it on the victims
and say you should have known better you
should have done this you should stop
but there there's no end no end to that
or do you go after the grifters
themselves and so that's what I realized
I realized like that's the tactic
that I went with